[Musique]
dans un jour avec ce soir la vie en
maison de retraite la semaine dernière
partout en france
le personnel des ehpad s'est mis en
grève pour protester contre le manque de
moyens à la réunion elle les personnes
âgées ont encore souvent la chance de
pouvoir rester auprès de leur famille
mais ce modèle traditionnel est en train
de changer jean marc collienne et
laurent fignon nous présente ce soir
juliette une jeune infirmière de l'ehpad
de bois d'olives à confronter souvent à
la solitude et à la souffrance des
gramounes c'est pour ouvrir les volets
il volait je monte un peu
il est 7 heures juliette vient de
prendre son service
le patient et malentendants et se
déplace difficilement
juliette l'infirmière et or fise les
deux soignantes l'aide pas seul
et elles vont le laisser marcher à son
rythme jusqu'à la salle de bain
très bien très très bien car c'est
pratiquement le seul trajet qu'il fait
encore à pied pendant que les deux
soignantes change des draps du lit
juliette procède à la toilette est ce
que la température mais bon je te laisse
poindre le pommeau de douche c'est trop
chaud c'est un peu vrai j'en profite
pour frotter un petit peu le dos la
toile est finie c'est un moment quai
paquet pas évident c'est pas toujours
facile avec les patients de la pudeur et
c'est oui
après on essaie vraiment de respecter
leurs capacités donc à les stimuler
beaucoup alors ce monsieur il entend pas
bien donc c'est vraiment le regard la
gestuelle et ça nous permet d'avoir un
échange vous allez manger il faut faire
la glycémie avant on pique le beau
dehors oui d'accord il faut la patience
il faut de la patience avec prend du
temps
we fall humilité aussi tu as fait laver
les pieds
poirier
et bon mais de rien puis va au petit
déjeuner tous utilisent les brouilles
avec son procès bonjour me sebbar et
comment il est
fallait bien quoi l'arrivée mois pour
les malades ou la burqa fait bien me
accompagna au petit déjeuner tu as des
douleurs à la hanche
d'accord bonjour tout le monde
[Musique]
quel accueil masse et marées
ça vous a troublé les papes du gua denis
accueille 90 pensionnaires avec un
encadrement de 55 agents affectés au
soin des patients
on est loin de l'objectif de 1 agent par
résident prévu par le plan de solidarité
grand âge adopté il ya maintenant dix
ans par le gouvernement
c'est bien le montrer par des personnes
très âgées
oui on a une dame de madame petit cadeau
elle est extraordinaire elle déambule
dans les couloirs elle est par là elle
est super on nous l'a présenté oui tu es
fatigué d'accord
c'est la doyenne de la maison oui
maintenant oui tu as quel âge madame
petit cadeau
[Musique]
68 je crois que c'était plus moi on m'a
dit que c'était 95
peut-être oui tu à 95 ans et tu as
encore bien en forme
l'ehpad de bois de lise accueille des
personnes âgées ou très âgés mais
parfois aussi et de plus en plus souvent
des patients plus jeunes présentant des
pathologies lourdes dans les familles ne
peuvent plus s'occuper
bonjour comment il est voilà bien dormi
oui moment on connaît comment y appelle
c'est juliette
ce patient par exemple est aveugle et
souffre d'épilepsie est endormi oui je
vais chercher les serviettes et je
t'accompagne ensuite à la bouche attends
je récupère ma main j'arrive à temps je
vais chercher le linge attends attends
attends
j'arrive charivari pour ceux résidant
on a juste posé un matelas par terre et
limiter au maximum le mobilier pour ne
pas qu'il se blesse en cas de crise
ça va bon allons dans la salle de
malheur
tu perds
est ce que tu veux aller aux toilettes
oui sur les toilettes je baisse le
pantalon un tué sur les toilettes à un
jeu se refait ton lit en attendant je te
laisse un petit peu tranquille je dirais
que c'est beaucoup plus qu'un travail
d'infirmière oui enfin c'est notre
propre semiacs endroit vraiment un café
oui oui oui
et toujours il faut prendre le temps
écoutez réconforter quoi l'arrivée
la patate et soeurs qui viennent te voir
mal après la venue dimanche
hier elle est venue comme ça beaucoup de
souffrance beaucoup de tristesse
oui oui à des moments et c'est vrai que
malheureusement c'est le matin quand on
les croise qu'ils ont besoin de se
décharger et c'est vrai que balla on
court un petit peu comme tout le monde a
envie d'avoir ces médicaments à l'heure
et sont très à cheval là dessus bonjour
tout le monde
tu peux tu peux aller s'installer et se
plaisait les médicaments assieds-toi
lama confrontés au manque de moyens
les personnels des ehpad se plaignent
souvent de n'être que des distributeurs
de médicaments
je ne pas avoir le temps de prendre
réellement soins des patients certains
parlent eux mêmes de maltraitance se
laisse moi tranquille
le personnel de bois de livres lui a le
sentiment de bénéficier de conditions de
travail plutôt favorables par rapport à
la plupart des autres établissements
merci bonne journée
dans les couloirs les grands principes
de l'accueil en ehpad sont rappelés
juliette elle les résume en un mot
l'humanitude c'est une philosophie
vraiment de prendre soin de la
bientraitance
c'est vrai qu'on utilise beaucoup à le
toucher la parole bateau et le personnel
de l'ehpad a pour cela un allié il
s'appelle tapis bonjour lui dit le rôle
important oui sourit vraiment ça compte
la preuve simone était en pleurs tout à
l'heure la tabbee lui a rendu le sourire